يقضي الأمريكيون الكثير من الوقت في العمل، وهو أمر
يتخلل حياتنا بأكملها
ويمكن أن يؤثر سلبًا خاصة في ظل
الظروف الصعبة. يمكن أن يكون لظروف العمل
تأثير هائل على صحتنا العقلية، حيث
يكشف تقرير جديد صدر يوم الثلاثاء من مراكز السيطرة على الأمراض والوقاية منها في عام 2021 عن واحد من كل
عانى 37 من البالغين العاملين الذين تتراوح أعمارهم بين 18 و64 عامًا من
ضائقة نفسية خطيرة شديدة
بما يكفي لتتطلب العلاج، وكانت المعدلات
أعلى بكثير بالنسبة لأولئك الذين
أفادوا أنهم اضطروا إلى العمل عندما يعانون من
مرض جسدي وكذلك بالنسبة لأولئك الذين
لم يتمكنوا من الحصول على إجازة مرضية مدفوعة الأجر
وكذلك الأشخاص الذين يعملون في وقت متأخر من الليل.  أو
التحولات الدورية في جداول زمنية مرنة
والأجور غير المتسقة تشير أيضًا إلى أن
الأشخاص الذين يعانون من ضعف الصحة العقلية يحتاجون إلى
شعور بالقوة في حياتهم، ويقول الدكتور دينيس
ستولي من جمعية علم النفس الأمريكية إن
السبب الرئيسي وراء
الضيق هو الحاجة إلى القدرة على
التنبؤ والمرونة حيث يمكن
للناس  لديهم القدرة على أن يكونوا قادرين على
الاعتماد على الأشياء الأساسية مثل أنهم
سيكونون قادرين على دفع
فواتيرهم مع راتبهم التالي.
نصيحته لأصحاب العمل لا تختار
بين الإنتاجية الاقتصادية
ورعاية الموظفين، فالأمران يسيران جنبًا إلى جنب  إن
الشعور بالسلامة النفسية في
مكان العمل يزيد من الإنتاجية ويزيد
الابتكار من معدل الاحتفاظ بالموظفين
ويكون له تأثير إيجابي على
النتيجة الاقتصادية النهائية